- Hi everyone, welcome to the
Daily Homeroom live stream.
I'm Sal from Khan Academy,
and I'm super excited
about our guest today.
So I'm actually just gonna
go through my announcements
pretty fast so that we have as much time
with Tom Friedman as possible.
But before we start,
I do like to make my
standard announcement that,
remember, Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
we only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And I do want to give a special shout out
to several corporations that
stepped up when they found out
that we needed to step up
more during this whole crisis.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly and Novartis, and
the many other corporations
and foundations that
have been supporting us,
even pre-COVID.
And we are running into deficit before,
this has definitely helped,
but we continue to run into deficit
because of the traffic on our servers
and all the programs that
we're trying to accelerate
because of COVID.
So if you are in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
So with that, I'm super
excited to introduce our guest,
Tom Friedman, I think
someone who doesn't need
much of an introduction,
a famous columnist,
an author from The New York Times,
Tom, great to see you.
- Sal, great to be with
you, this is great.
- So I'm glad you joined.
I don't think there's a lot to talk about,
not much interesting
going on in the world,
but I figure, we're good at killing time.
(laughs)
So where do we start?
I am curious.
Your vantage point of all of the things
that are now kind of have
been thrown up in the air
from the healthcare crisis,
the economic crisis,
obviously even there's
an education crisis,
maybe there's political stuff going on
and obviously Khan Academy,
we're a non-political
organization, so we try to stay
a little bit clear about
some of those conversations.
But I'm curious,
from your point of view as
a columnist and an author,
you've written books about globalization,
The World is Flat, all of these things.
What do you think is the biggest aha!
Of this moment?
- I think there are two
Sal, that really are shaping
how I cover this story.
The first is my youngest daughter,
Natalie actually is the executive producer
of All Things Considered
weekend edition on NPR
so I never miss it.
And on Easter Sunday they did a roundup
of a pastor sermons
from around the country.
And I particularly was struck
by Michael Curry's sermon
from the National Cathedral,
because he ended it with a song.
He started singing,
♪ He's got the whole world in His hands ♪
♪ He's got the whole
wide world in His hands ♪
♪ He's got the whole world in His hands ♪
I think what is, for me--
- Tom, you're pretty good singer
- (laughs) I don't think so, but (mumbles)
- That was ... Anyway,
but yeah, please continue.
- What is the Uber story for me?
So what has really shaped my
thinking more than anything
about this story, is that
just substitute he for she.
For the first time Mother
Nature has us all in her hands.
For the first time our
generation of human species,
'cause I don't think
any of us are virtually,
any of us were here in 1918,
the last time she had us all in her hands,
the last time there was a global pandemic.
For the first time, we all
are facing one of nature's
challenges together as a species.
And Mother Nature throws
fastballs at us: droughts, floods,
wildfires, germs, viruses, pandemics,
and these other way ultimately
natural selection happens,
for plants and animals.
This is how she sorts out the fittest.
And this is the first
time all of us together
have faced this kind of
challenge, this kind of fastball.
Now, so Mother Nature,
one of the things you always
have to keep in mind is
she actually doesn't reward the smartest.
She also doesn't reward the strongest.
She actually rewards the most adaptive
when she throws her fastballs.
Who can actually adapt best.
And in the face of a pandemic,
she really is saying to us,
"I reward three kinds of adaptation.
First, I reward humility.
Do you respect my virus?
Because if you don't respect my virus,
it will hurt you or someone you love.
Second, are you coordinated
in facing my virus?
Because I evolve my viruses over millennia
to find any crack in your immune system.
So unless you are really
coordinated in your response
my virus will find that crack."
And lastly, because Mother
Nature herself is just chemistry,
biology and physics, she says,
"I only reward adaptation strategies
that are based on chemistry,
biology, and physics.
If your adaptation strategy
is based on politics, ideology
or an election schedule,
it won't be effective."
And so for me Sal that's
kind of the Uber framework
at which I look at everything,
I judge the responses
and is the lens through
which I'm doing my analysis.
- Actually there's a ton of
questions already coming in.
I do wanna remind everyone watching
if you have any questions
for, especially Tom,
including me, feel free to put
them on the message boards,
on YouTube and Facebook,
we have team members who are
going to surface that to us.
But given what you just said,
which I think is a really
good way of thinking about it
because so many times
where we're caught up
in our human bubble, but
we are on this planet
and there are forces
(chuckles) that can humble us
very, very, very quickly.
How do you think, well,
let me ask the question,
how do you think this is gonna play out?
How do you think it's gonna
play out in the short term?
And what do you think are
gonna be, maybe the medium
and longterm implications of all this?
- Well, what I would
say is that what you see
are three broad responses of adaptation
playing out in the world today.
So one, let's call it the
super efficient lockdown
and then test, trace,
track and quarantine model.
And probably the most super
efficient form of that
is China 'cause it uses
basically a surveillance system
that it uses for controlling a society
to now track and trace the coronavirus.
So that's one model.
And then there are
democratic versions of that,
Germany, South Korea, et cetera,
and they've also been quite effective,
Taiwan, New Zealand to name a few.
At the other extreme you
have the model being ...
And by the way, China is doing that,
they hope to actually
completely quash COVID-19
in their society and
the spread of transition
until there is a vaccine.
'Cause you only can
overcome a virus like this
when there is herd immunity,
and there's only two ways
to get herd immunity.
One is through a vaccine
and the other is by 60
to 70% of your population
actually getting the infection
and overcoming it naturally
by developing the antibodies.
(phone ringing)
Excuse me.
- No worries.
- So that's the China model.
The second model is a Swedish model,
and Sweden, well, they don't
like to say it directly,
basically has gone for
natural herd immunity.
Their model was actually
keep their economy open,
close colleges and high schools,
but let K-9 schools operate,
let malls and restaurants open
but encourage social
distancing, mass squaring
and protect the most vulnerable in theory,
which they didn't do
very well in practice.
Actually let the young
and the least vulnerable,
those who will experience this
just as a mild flu likely,
or tough flu but will not
require hospitalization
to develop herd immunity.
And bet that the number of
people who will get the disease
and not require ICU units or ventilators
will be less than sign
the number of ICU units
and ventilators you have.
That's the Swedish model.
And the case is still out there,
I mean, we just don't know if
they've had a lot more deaths
than their neighbors.
Obviously they're arguing
that the real test
will be in three months,
whether they have herd immunity
and they're done with this or not,
but there's a lot of
controversy around that
and there's simply no way
to judge at this stage.
The third model is America,
and we're a mess, Sal.
We basically, we talk
like we're gonna be China.
We act like we're going
to be Sweden by default.
We are really not preparing to do either,
and our president's arguing
we're superior to both.
So it's kind of a mess basically.
And you have some states
where it's working well,
others where it's working, not well,
people who are wearing
masks, people who+ aren't.
And I go back to Mother Nature
'cause she actually doesn't know, Sal
where the border between
Georgia and Florida is.
And she really is not
interested in your lockdown
or if you were tired of being locked down,
she really is only gonna respect
your adaptation strategy.
- I mean, so what do you think
the implications are?
I mean, just for the US and the world,
I mean, even for a China or even a Sweden,
well, I guess the herd immunity
could be very effective,
but a place like China,
obviously at some point
they're gonna wanna open up their borders.
So even if they are able to
squash it in the short term
to your point, Mother
Nature also does not know
the borders of countries.
If you just take a realist point of view,
there's a world where you advocate
for one policy or another.
But if you just say like,
the world is already on a trajectory,
and there's gonna be political forces
and economic forces at play,
what do you see as the next
six to 12 months looking like?
When you look at the stock
market, it looks like,
at least the US stock market
looks like we're all clear
(laughs) things are on ... I mean,
what's your best guess
as a prognosticator?
- Yeah, I read, an analyst
the other day said,
the stock market's priced in
everything except a recession,
related to the virus is quite remarkable,
but it's in its own universe basically.
What do I think is gonna happen,
let me start with what
I'm praying will happen.
I'm praying that Moore's
law will defeat COVID's law.
That basically you gotta race
right now between Moore's law
and COVID's law.
COVID's law is about the speed
with which one single person
can impact three others and
three others, three others,
and how quickly this virus can spread.
Moore's law says the speed
and power of microchips
will double every 24 months.
And so basically it's a proxy
for technological advance.
And since 1918, Lord knows
we have technology tools now
that we're applying to biology
that just didn't exist before.
And I'm hoping that they
will give us a vaccine
or therapies at a minimum
that will take death off the table.
But a vaccine that by
the end of this year,
early next year will allow
us to get through a vaccine
a high degree of recurred
immunity around the world,
that's my hope.
Beyond that, it's really
outside my skillset.
I listen to what the biologists say,
the virologist, that they expect
that we will get a second wave,
we'll get a second wave in part
because people just aren't practicing
smart habits of social
distancing and masking
and not collecting in groups,
and we may get a second wave
because the thing about this disease
which makes it so beguiling is that,
first of all, it comes in decaf,
regular and double macchiato.
And so first of all, many people get it
and are completely asymptomatic,
and the next person next to you gets it,
and these are respirators.
And so it clearly interacts
with different bodies,
different DNA, different
comorbidities, different latitudes
and different populations
and different temperatures differently.
And so I think you just
really have to respect it
and be humble.
And so I listen to what the biologists say
and they're all basically telling us
there's going to be a second wave
and you listen to people
like the epidemiologist,
Mike Osterholm from the
University of Minnesota
and Tom Frieden, the
former head of the CD.C.,
would just say that this thing
will just keep infecting us
until it runs out of people.
So unless we develop either natural
or immunological herd immunity,
so a vaccine or immunity.
So I'm quite humble about it.
Sal, I try not to get over my skis.
- And what's your sense
given even that somewhat hopeful picture
of hopefully we can get a
vaccine near the end of the year,
early next year.
Let's talk about people being able to have
some type of antiviral therapies,
maybe sooner that to your point takes
at least death off the table,
but that still might be in
November timeframe type thing.
What do you think is going to
happen from kind of a economic
and societal point of view?
'Cause even, we've seen
what's happened to unemployment
just over the last six
or eight weeks.
What do you think is gonna
change about people's behavior,
the economy, I don't wanna
get too much into the politics
and who's doing right or wrong,
but how might that
broadly affect politics?
- Well, it's a really important
question you're asking.
Let me just talk a little
bit about my own life,
I'm talking to you from our
home in Bethesda, Maryland.
My wife Ann's been building
a museum to promote reading
and literacy in Washington D.C.
it's called planning word,
planningwordmuseum.org.
And we were about 90% done.
We actually were supposed
to open next week,
so that's been put on hold.
But here's what I have noticed,
so you and I are having a conversation now
via this technology, is
Google technology platform.
And I'd say Sal, it's about 85%
is good as when I used
to come to your office,
and you and I would sit
there across from your desk,
but it's a 100% less stress on you and me,
and we're reaching a wide audience.
And so I have been having the most rich,
deep Zoom conversations
now around the world.
I started this morning
with a friend in Mumbai.
I'm doing this now with
you, it's just a treat.
And then this evening
I'm doing with a friend
from a consulting firm.
I had a day, a couple of weeks ago,
where I did the India Today
platform in New Delhi.
I then spoke to 82 UN ambassadors
for the small ambassadors
coalition at the UN.
And I ended the day with
the ballot form in Beijing.
And I never left my seat here at home.
And these were not facile interactions,
They're actually, they felt deep.
And so this will change my world.
This will enable me to act globally.
When I wrote The World Is Flat,
what the book was
basically arguing is that,
what made the world flat?
The reason I was making that argument
was that what we were seeing
was not globalization.
In the old days to be global,
you had to be a country,
and then the old days to be
global, you to be a company.
What was new?
That's what I was writing about
when I wrote that book in 2005.
What was new is the ability now
individuals to act globally,
Spell and Tom are now
acting globally, okay.
And as individuals, and I think that
is only going to accelerate more and more.
I wanna hear from you what
this means for education.
And I've been talking to my
daughter early about that too.
Obviously this is not going
away 'cause this technology
is just going to get better and better.
And I can only imagine so,
but I do believe we're
gonna see more automation
'cause machines don't infect each other,
and we're going to see a
lot of companies realize,
The New York Times has been closed
from pretty much the first
week in March, we're closed.
They announced we're not
coming back to the office
till the end of summer, till
Labour Day, at the earliest.
That includes the Washington Bureau I work
and The New York Office.
And I'm proud to say we are putting out
the most amazing
newspaper every single day
and none of us are in the office.
Now, I don't know exactly
what the implications of that
are gonna be, but they're
going to be implications.
And I'm just trying to get
my mind around that now.
- No, I mean, you're
touching on a lot of things.
I have to say, a lot of people,
they start calls these days
and say, "How are you doing?"
And I say relatively speaking, "I'm fine."
A lot of people are
suffering much more (mumbles)
I almost feel guilt that to your point,
there's aspects of this
that I think have been a boon
(chuckles) and they've not--
- (mumbles)
- I've talked about it.
I don't enjoy planes for
a whole bunch of reasons,
I get claustrophobic on
them and all of that.
But just the time, the energy
and then being able to have
fairly good interactions \
with folks all over the world like this
I think it is a new world.
And to your point, like
the New York Times,
Khan Academy, we are already,
we're reasonably distributed,
but even more so, the team
is as functional as ever,
I mean, the main issue is
the team members have child care issues
while they're working from home.
But if that wasn't an issue,
I think a lot of folks are appreciating
not having to commute, not
having to get on planes.
And so it is a bit of a
brave new world for everyone
that maybe we'll have some positives.
- We're privileged I have a job,
I work for a healthy
organization that laid me off.
And so I understand
what a minority this is,
but in terms of just
how these technologies
are not gonna go away, I think they will,
they're going to infuse
throughout our society,
and the longer this goes on
'cause the technologies will get better,
the more remote learning,
remote work, remote lectures
I think will become part of the norm.
And I am curious about that last point
'cause I think both you and
I we are very fortunate,
we have jobs we can do remotely,
which I think is maybe
one of the most important
things right now.
Given how many people,
especially in the service sector,
in restaurants, airlines,
tourism, and now other things,
people losing their jobs,
record high unemployment in
our lifetimes, maybe ever,
we don't know when this is gonna end.
And to your point it might accelerate
if factories lean even more on automation
because you can't transmit
the virus and all of that,
what's going to happen
to all of these folks?
How are we going to be able to make sure
that people stay engaged in society
and they feel productive?
And will it be temporary or
will it be somewhat structural?
Even if we get the vaccine.
One of the point Sal,
I did a dialogue one day
with my friend Michael Sandel
who teaches the justice course at Harvard,
and we did a column together earlier on,
what is the common good in a pandemic.
Michael made this point,
it really struck me.
And when you look around Sal
and look at all the people
and all the jobs we are now depending on,
people will go in and
stop grocery shelves,
people will go in and butcher meat
at meat packing factories,
people who drive the truck
from the meat packing
factory to the grocery store,
the processing plant.
All the people who ...
Every crisis throws up different heroes,
and 911, it was first responders,
and this one is first responders too.
But now it's all these
people who do traditionally,
it wouldn't be wrong to
say we're looked down upon,
do your homework, study Khan Academy.
so you don't have to be a truck driver.
It would have been a cliche,
you would have heard out there.
These people are heroes now.
They're actually the ones saving us.
And by going to work,
they're actually risking their lives.
Think of someone who
sits in a grocery store
all day, stocking shelves,
and we need to find a way
to honor these people after this is over.
My friend Dov Seidman says,
right now we're busy saving people,
but after this leaders need to figure out
how to serve people.
We need to make a pivot after this
and make sure that these people
have the kind of health care,
have the kind of family care,
child care and access to
education that they deserve,
that everyone in our society deserves.
And that it's really got
me certainly thinking
a lot more about that.
And I've never been a big fan
of universal basic income only
'cause I think dignity is so much derived
from work and working,
but the way we've been dividing the pie
is not sustainable.
And out of this I think
needs to come a real,
a different division of the pie,
more for labor than for capital
and safety nets that are reward and honor
these people who we now
find out are so important
for the functioning of our society.
- And what's your sense, there's
a bunch of questions here
from Facebook and YouTube.
Tim Kearney asks,
he's referring to your
kind of Darwinian frame
that you started with.
If COVID-19 is survival of the fittest,
what responsibility does
the Federal Government have
to support the least fit?
And I'll add a little bit
to it 'cause this takes,
I would say maybe a health
angle, the least fit,
but also as we just touched
about the economically
vulnerable as well, and there
is this really hard tension
that you might save
people with the shutdowns
on the COVID side, but it
might lead to more poverty,
more unemployment, hunger,
and all sorts of forms
of death are correlated
with not having a job
and not having income.
So how does someone weigh that?
Well, how do you thread that needle?
- It's really important
question and I would say,
from the very beginning
and in the beginning
it was controversial.
I was one of the very first people writing
that the strategy we need is one
of what Dr. David Cass called
total harm minimization.
How do we maximize saving lives
and saving livelihoods?
Because there's a lot of ways to die,
you can die immediately by COVID-19,
and you can die longterm
by a death of despair,
of unemployment, of
loss of hope and income.
And both are thrown up by this fires.
Sometimes people do say,
"Whoa, that sounds really Darwinian."
Guess what, it is.
When we're all in the grip
of Mother Nature, it is,
there are no easy solutions.
And the point is to respect to me
both sides of that equation.
How do we maximize saving lives?
Maximize saving livelihoods?
And it seem to me the way you do that,
and this was what people like
Carts were talking about,
Amnon Shashoua in Israel.
Basically you're locked down,
you break the chains of transmission,
you protect the most vulnerable.
You literally don't let
them go out and you pointed
and sequester them.
And then on a risk stratified basis,
you feed back into the workforce.
The people who are most likely
to experience the virus,
either asymptomatically
or as a mild or tough flu,
not require hospitalization
and let them keep the economy running
or get it running again,
it had to be that kind of a strategy.
One of the big problems we have Sal,
and I'm not gonna get into
politics here any more
than I need to, but we haven't
had a national navigator.
And so basically the public
here has been caught between
what I call breaking news
and president breaking bad.
Okay, so you're watching the
news and suddenly breaks in
and tells you that 24
kids in the New York area
experience COVID-19 is dramatic
and dangerous information.
But what you're not told is
that 24 to 24, 24 to 240,
24 to 2,400, 24 to 240,000,
if there's one lesson,
I hope you're teaching,
it's the difference between
denominator and numerator.
And when you know what the denominator is
and breaking news is constantly in there
hitting you with breaking
news that a 24 year old
died of a stroke or whatever.
And if you don't know
what is the denominator,
what is the numerator, how
do I put this in perspective?
So you have that on one side
and then you have a president
who's not wearing a mask
using hydroxychloroquine
that its own FDA rejects
and putting out crazy ideas about Lysol
and ultraviolet light.
And so we have not had,
like New Zealand has had
a calm voice at the top,
educating you, uniting us,
making clear that we're
all in this together.
So don't go to a restaurant without a mask
or crowded in there,
that's not a sign of macho,
that's a sign of disrespect
to your neighbor,
to your family, to your grandparents.
This is not us against each other,
This is us against all of us,
against Mother Nature's fastball.
And we really need to
think of it that way.
- Now, and there are a lot
more questions coming in
on Facebook, these are two
related, Roger Stevens asks,
what are the biggest societal changes
you think we'll see
coming out of the pandemic
and Tim Kearney, I teach first grade,
what type of long-term
changes do you foresee
for my colleagues and students?
How are they better or
are they just necessary?
How will they be temporary
versus new normal?
So it's really two questions of
what's gonna be the new norm?
And we talked a little bit,
maybe the nature of work changes,
maybe a lot fewer people
slept into the office
with that long commute sitting in traffic,
maybe we travel less,
which frankly I would love.
What are other things that
you think might happen?
- So, one of the things, I've
been a journalist (mumbles)
since 1979, so it was my 40th year,
and actually in '78 I started.
And so if I look back at my career,
the stories I'd most like to take back,
the stories in columns
began with this sentence,
the world will never be the same again.
That's a dangerous sentence.
So I'm humble about that
too, I wanna be very careful.
But what it's clear to me
is pandemics to accelerate
existing trends and they often
exacerbate existing fractures.
And clearly they are going to,
this one is going to
accelerate distance learning,
distance work and replacing travel
with this kind of
teleporting, telecommuting,
telemedicine that I think
is just gonna become
more and more effective and efficient.
And so I mean, I've
seen Zoom presentations.
I know you can do it on
this Google platform too
now with graphics, and it's
just gonna get so good.
That clearly that's
gonna be an Uber trend.
Beyond that, it seems to
me another broad trend,
and this is a phrase that
my friend Seidman uses.
First, we work with our
hands for generations,
millennial, then we work with our heads,
computing the information economy,
and going forward more we're
gonna work with our hearts,
we're gonna work with things
that connect people-to-people,
and that require
people-to-people connections
and enhance people-to-people connections.
So I have a motto, if you're
not in the community business,
you're not in business today,
that is in the retail sense.
If you're not creating
a community experience,
you are just the next company
that's gonna be devoured by Amazon.
Because if all you have
is a price arbitrage,
there's going to be somebody bigger
and more efficient at that.
So things that connect people-to-people,
like I really love what we're doing,
but I will love going out of this
and sitting around in
my backyard with friends
who can come over six feet apart
even more after I've
spent a day doing this.
So I just think that it's
gonna be more and more work
of connecting hearts-to-hearts,
and the machines will
be doing the head stuff.
My friend Ravi Kumar who
runs Mphasis actually,
the Indian high-tech firm.
Ravi basically says in the future
machines will do the problem solving
and people will do the problem finding.
And that's why Mphasis for instance
is hiring fewer STEM people
and more anthropologists
and psych (mumbles).
People who can find problems.
That was Steve Jobs, he's genius,
he knew you wanted an iPhone
before you knew it and he's
the great example of that.
But problem finders I think
are gonna be in great demand
and then we'll let the AI
and the machine and the bot
be the problem solvers.
I think that shift is gonna happen more.
It's something you might wanna
be thinking about it at con,
you know what I mean?
We surely, look, you can't
be a good problem finder
if you don't know math
and you aren't literate
and you don't know history and whatnot,
but ultimately, is that a
vein for con to be mining,
the idea of problem finding.
It'd be interesting to have
a course in problem finding.
- Yeah, I've never
thought about it that way,
but it makes a lot of sense
that the problem definition
and recognizing there's a need.
Now that makes, and then
maybe on that last point,
'cause it does kind of touch
on careers of the future
and all of that, I've been
having a lot of conversations
with young people, it's graduation time,
you can imagine there's a lot of anxiety,
there's always anxiety of that age.
But especially in this,
we have a couple of questions from folks.
Ashley Paskal sounds like
she's a young journalist,
how should she navigate
her career during COVID-19?
But I'll broaden the question,
what advice do you have for young people
entering the world into a
very, very tough job market,
a world where things
are an incredible flux.
What advice would you have for them?
- I guess one of the
things that I said earlier,
this exact survey, it's current trends.
So if you are, for instance,
an established journalists,
so I can just call some up
and say that "Zoom" and you can call me up
and say, "Tom, let's just Zoom in"
And bam, we do it."
It's like that.
But I pity someone who can't do that.
So Zoom is only good if I can call you up
and you will be the counterparty.
But this is such a challenging
time to start out in,
at the same time 'cause these
things always go both ways.
It's like a whole new world.
And there's such virgin territory
there to be reported on,
so many motherloads of
emotion and psychology
now playing out.
And if you can find a
platform to publish on,
an online platform or
somehow create your own,
you don't have to be
at the New York Times,
you can break in now, like never before.
And so my advice always for
young journalists is that,
is write, write, write
and write some more.
That is the only way you
learn how to be a journalist,
is to write and develop
a mountain of clips
that show how you can write
the issues you can take on,
the stories you can frame and find.,
and that's how you build a reputation.
But there's no other way,
I mean, going to journalism
school now through Zoom,
doesn't strike me as very productive.
So I have a lot of sympathy
for people starting out now.
My mind's been elsewhere, frankly,
for the last couple of months
but I need to think more about that,
it's a very good question.
But the most important thing you can do,
the thing that always works
is write and get published.
And by the way, it doesn't matter
whether it's for your
neighborhood shopper,
your local community newspaper,
your blog, your online,
just something that can show your talent,
that you can show someone
else for them to say,
"Hey, that was pretty good,
I'm gonna give you a chance."
- And I'll add to that.
I'm not a journalist, you
very much are a journalist,
but some of the stuff that you pointed out
is stuff that I felt too, is that,
there's all this reporting in the media,
but sometimes people are
like losing the meat of it,
they're reporting, this
state has this many cases,
that state has (mumbles).
Well, what's the per capita?
Like how at risk will I be?
They're losing that, yes,
there is a young person
who had this symptom
and it's really scary,
but give the context of,
guess what, there's always
been one in a million cases
of really horrible things happening.
So that might not be that as
different as the media implies.
So whether someone's
going to get into starting
in journalism or any other field,
because everything is thrown
up in the air right now.
There are opportunities
to maybe find niches,
just be kind of an evolutionary terms
that might not have been there before.
Our ancestors wouldn't have
come out of their holes
if the dinosaurs weren't hit
by (laughs) the meteorite.
So Tom, thank you so much for this.
Whenever we have a good conversation
the time goes unusually fast.
We're already over time,
but I really appreciate this
and I hope we can do this again
and we can have more of these
highly stimulating Zoom conversations.
- Absolutely Sal.
Thank you very much.
Thanks to all the people who
tuned in, I really enjoyed it.
- Thanks so much.
- Goodbye.
- So everyone, thanks again.
As you can tell, these conversations
are always super fun for myself.
Hopefully you'll have enjoyed it as well.
I've actually, the reason
why I'm in the office,
is the socially distance, I'm
the only one in the office.
I don't think they've turned
the air conditioner on today.
So that's why I might be looking
a little bit more shiny than normal.
But it's always incredibly
stimulating for myself,
and I look forward to
seeing you'll in future,
I guess we could call them episodes.
Tomorrow, it'll be just me,
and I'm happy to take any
questions you have about anything.
So with that, I will
see everyone tomorrow.